welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and Harwin strong has got
it going on but he's dead now so we're
moving on to the next one with episode 7
of House of the Dragon throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
the brand new trailer and also
discussing what we think is going on due
to what happens in the books because of
this there will be heavy spoilers here
and I'm not cutting my tongue out to
hold the secrets on what happens so get
out of here if you don't want to know
and if you enjoy the breakdown Smash It
Like It's Joffrey lawnmouth and please
subscribe for videos like this every day
by the way thank you for clicking this
now let's get into the house of the
Dragon trailer
what is this brief mortal life
if not the pursuit of legacy
we play an ugly game
if you want to be a strong Queen your
subjects must fear you
fire is such strange power
everything that House Targaryen
possesses his own spirit
there is a debt to be paid
this is the highest of treasons
I promise you in time you and I together
will prevail
now they see
okay so the episode seems like it's
playing fast and least with a lot of
events from the source material and
combining a number of things in one
location to potentially pull together
numerous different plot points by the
looks of it the majority of the episode
is taking place in driftmark around the
time of Lena's funeral this is a big
event in which a character gets her
dragon vagar and houses separate even
further than before we open with her
sagovagus which is based on ones used in
ancient Egypt you can see the seahorse
sigil on the bottom which belongs to the
house and also a strong focus on the
hair which the valerians were known for
she's then given a Burial at Sea with a
coffin being dumped into the ocean
similar to how the Navy might give
someone a funeral the books describe how
callers had amass the largest Navy in
the world which explains why he carried
things out this way next we see the
family standing together and this
combination of characters makes me think
that most of this episode will take
place in one location notice that
raniera is wearing red and black whereas
Allison and her children are wearing
green further hinting to towards the
greens vs Black Civil War that's
building in the household now we cut to
Rainey sinkhole is talking about Legacy
whilst looking completely deflated
though in my episode 6 breakdown I said
I thought this entry might center around
the red spring I am kind of going back
and forth on that I won't spoil it at
that come from that but there are a
couple of them that the valerians get
involved in next we see Lena's Dragon
Vega the biggest in Westeros this killed
her at the end of the last episode and
it's now rivalist though not for very
long in the teaser they drop a line
about how this has been stolen and it
appears to be to Sir Kristen Cole
knowing the books this involved aymond
who ended up traveling out a driftmark
with the rest of his family he was told
by his father that they could go into
Dragonstone and he could claim a
hatchling rather than trying to tame a
giant Beast this angered him quite a lot
and that night he ended up sticking out
in order to tame Vega the mightiest of
all the dragons in the realm this was a
similar scene to what played out in
episode 6 but instead of being scared he
jumped on the back of vagar and ended up
riding it into the night because he was
sneaking out Geoffrey ended up following
him and he shouted out how he'd snitch
which is a big No-No no snitching now
Eamon kicked him into a pile of dragon
droppings and upon his return he started
shouting about how they were all strongs
by this point the rest of his brothers
had shown up to help out the younger one
and Luke Harris ended up slashing out
eamon's eye now I used this in the last
video but here's one of the rare images
in the book shows him cutting it out and
hopefully we get a similar scene like
this in the episode I don't know why I
said hopefully not like I like seeing
kids cutting other kids its eyes out I'm
not a psychopath but I suppose my mum
was right when she said if you're not
careful you'll end up shooting your eye
out now he was completely blinded by
this I think the main conflict in this
episode will be because Alison wanted an
eye for an eye she refers to how there's
a debt to be paid and we see what I
believe is lucaris getting knocked down
to the floor Alice until the king now
the only way to settle it would be to
cut lucaris's eye out and it looks like
she's even grabbing the cat's poor
dagger I think she probably goes to stab
him but this is when she's stubbed by
renero who says she sees her as she
truly is now in the books this scene
wasn't nearly as dramatic as it appears
to be and ranera ended up getting
viserys to calm things down she said
that Eamonn saying that they were
Strong's was tantamount to treason which
is why I think we also get this line in
the teaser this is the highest of
treasons zaris Saw both as being really
bad and he obviously he just wanted to
get back to his train set so he said the
strong thing was as bad as the eye thing
and that the ordeal was now settled Biz
actually put out the message that anyone
who said that they were Strong's would
be classed as traitors to the realm and
he had the tongues cut out of two people
who did this a thing that they gave this
scene to larrison episode 6 but they
might also end up dropping a similar one
here Eamonn also came to appreciate the
day and he's quoted as saying that
though he lost an eye he gained a dragon
instead now pay close attention to this
room namely the staircase and
dragon-like teeth that we see in the
background at the start of the teaser we
get the adults all huddling around this
place looking at what I'm guessing is
Alison if you look closely at the kid at
the front you might also notice that he
has blood around his face which leads me
to believe this happens just after he's
hit there also seems to be a fight on
what maybe this staircase though I can't
really tell who this is even though it's
it's definitely a Targaryen seems like
they break someone's neck but I can't
find anyone else wearing the shade of
gray in the trailer we do get this shot
later on but again it's way too
difficult to make out who these people
are either way this whole thing splits
the houses even further with Alison now
thinking it's okay do attack the others
since they did it to her kids she's got
help too and after Laris took out Harwin
her father Otto can once more become the
hand of the king he's rehired and this
gives her another person on the council
who can influence viserys to do what she
says we get a close-up of the hand of
the Kingpin and this is no doubt him
proudly rocking it once more as he
returns to the realm his also Harris too
who will likely be appointed the master
of Whispers at this point he's gonna be
in this entry and he slowly moved the
pieces about so he's close to those in
power it also looks like there might be
some bits where they talk about the
prophecy of a Targaryen being on the
throne the other strongs are as much
targaryens as Alison's are I can see her
using this to say why they shouldn't be
heirs the bleached blonde hair that they
have was a way to show that they have
the blood of the Dragon in them and thus
by being brunette she can probably play
up that they're not true targaryens the
prophecy is one of the utmost important
things to viserys and potentially this
idea could be used to purge that he
needs to rethink the whole Earth thing
with jakaris the fact that illegitimate
might also make it harder for people to
accept they should be on the throne and
at the time many were slowly starting to
support aegon he was a male Heir which
many thought should supersede a female
one and Alison weaponizes against
rhaenyra to cast out her claim it's all
sort of hanging on viserys at the moment
but it's good to see that he actually
looks better than last week in the books
he ended up regaining a lot of his
health and he held a big banquet here
Eamon toasted to his family and he once
more called the kids the strongs which
caused a lot of [ __ ] now the reason I
said we might be getting the red spring
is to delay nor fighting with a sword
from the back this appears to be Lord
Carl who in the Box it said was jealous
that he was in love with another Knight
caused a big fight but who lived and who
died I shall not spoil and he'll have to
wait until next week or read the book or
or probably check out the wiki which you
get away with that either way that's the
video and I'd love to hear your thoughts
on what you think is gonna happen we are
in a competition right now giving away
three copies of doll love and thunder on
the 15th of October and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the trailer
we beat the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now save
that to you then message me on Twitter
at heavy spoilers if you want some else
to watch then make sure you check out
our Brighton of episode 6 which will be
linked on screen right now so our
favorite one so far lots of things going
on with it so definitely head over there
right after this by the way thanks for
singing through the video I've been Paul
I'll see in the next one take care peace